as knowledge increases could the pace of
scientific discovery slow as more and
more problems are solved
fortunately nature is as generous with
its problems as Nobel was with his
fortune the more we know the more aware
we are of what we know not indeed the
most important product of knowledge is
ignorant the questions we ask today are
more profound and more interesting than
those asked years ago when I was a
student many of those we have answered
but back then we did not possess enough
knowledge to be intelligently ignorant
and to ask the wonderful questions we
asked today some wonder whether someday
we will arrive at a theory of everything
and run out of new problems to solve
much as the effort to explore the earth
ran out of new continents to explore
while this is conceivably possible I am
happy to report that there is no
evidence that we are running out of our
most important resource ignorance how
lucky for science how lucky for
scientists and how lucky for the Nobel
Foundation thank you